just wanted to see if you could
recognize through this one of my best
friends right there Joe Rogan how did
you recognize him I just got tats all
the way down both of his arms his head's
holy shaved don't don't mess with that
guy that's the toughest guy in Hollywood
right there tougher than Jason Statham
do we want to start a beef he would take
Jason Statham if he wanted to throw a
blonde wig on Jason Statham and turn him
into his girlfriend he could do that
you don't want to mess around with Joe
he's a stoner too so you think he'd be
like more mellow well no he's the only
guy who's most weed and gets more in
touch
he's the greatest he's very hairy too
isn't that
got some hair on him he's never been
here
he's gonna be defending him yeah
so you know I know from experience he's
Olive smooth